PLAY.
FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
THE DEMOCRATS AND MANY ON THIS
THE LEFT WORKED AROUND THE CLOCK
TO KILL BRETT KAVANAUGH’S
NOMINATION TO THE SUPREME COURT.
BUT I THINK THEY MADE A FAY
NATURAL MISCALCULATION.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS OKAY ALONG
THE WAY TO JETTISON THE
PRINCIPLE OF DUE PROCESS, AND TO
USE VICTIMS TO PURSUE A RADICAL
POLITICAL AGENDA.
ON THE FIRST YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT, I THINK
IT’S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
THIS ALL STARTED WITH LIBERAL
DEMOCRAT HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
FRIEND OF BILL AND HILLARY, AND
OF COURSE BARACK OBAMA, AND
REMEMBER HE, THE HOLLYWOOD
MOGUL, MEGADONOR.
I MEAN THIS GUY IS WHERE IT ALL
HAPPENED.
AND, REMEMBER, THE ABUSE THERE
STARTED THE CULTURAL MOMENT OF
"ME TOO."
THIS NOTION OF OBJECT TY FIEING
WOMEN AND USING THEM FOR THE
PLEASURE OF THE POWERFUL HAS
BEEN LONG NURTURED BY THE LEFT.
AT THE SAME TIME IT WAS ALSO
PRO-WOMEN AS WE ABUSE WOMEN ON
THE CASTING COUCH, ET CETERA.
AND ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY, HAD
THE TARGET ON ITS BACK.
BUT NOW WE SEE THE SAME
MENTALITY AT PLAY IN THE
KAVANAUGH STRUGGLE.
CLAIMING TO BE DEFENDERS OF
WOMEN, THE DEMOCRATS CYNICALLY
AND I THINK CRUELLY USE
CHRISTINE FORD IN A DESPERATE
ATTEMPT TO DERAIL A SUPREME
COURT NOMINEE.
REMEMBER, SHE DIDN’T IISH IN
REMEMBER, SHE DIDN’T IISH
INIALLY WANT TO COME FORWARD,
SHE WAS DRAGGED INTO THE OPEN BY
POLITICAL LIKES TO THE
"WASHINGTON POST" AND OTHER
MEDIA OUTLETS.
REPORTERS SURROUNDED HER HOME,
AND THEN SHE WAS FORCED TO TELL
HER STORY.
AND TODAY, WE LEARNED OF MORE
DIRTY TRICKS FROM THE ACTIVIST
LAWYERS BEHIND THE SCENES.
REMEMBER LELAND KIZER?
SHE WAS THE PERSON WHO FORD
CLAIMED WAS AT THE PARTY WHERE
KAVANAUGH ALLEGEDLY ASSAULTED
HER.
ONE OF HER CLOSE FRIENDS.
WELL, KIZER PREVIOUSLY TOLD THE
SENATE COMMITTEE THAT SHE DIDN’T
SENATE COMMITTEE THAT SHE DIDN’TKNOW OF SUCH PARTY, DIDN’T KNOW
KNOW OF SUCH PARTY, DIDN’T KNOW
KAVANAUGH TO BEGIN WITH.
TODAY, THOUGH, SHE TOLD THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" THAT IN --
ANOTHER FRIEND OF FORDED,
AND THE FBI THAT A FORMER AGENT,
PRESSURED HER TO CHANGE HER
ACCOUNT TO CORROBORATE FORD’S
ACCOUNT.
UNBELIEVABLE.
WELL, IN A SPEECH ANNOUNCING HER
DECISION TO VOTE FOR KAVANAUGH’S
CONFIRMATION TODAY, SUSAN
COLLINS PERFECTLY SUMMED UP THE
CALLOUSNESS OF THE DEMOCRATS.
>> SOME PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO
ENGINEER THE DEFEAT OF THIS
NOMINATION CARED LITTLE, IF AT
ALL, FOR HER WELL BEING.
FORD TESTIFIED THAT A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE HAD ACCESS TO
HER LETTER.
YET THAT LETTER FOUND ITS WAY
INTO THE PUBLIC DOMAIN.
>> Laura: TODAY DIANNE FEINSTEIN
LEFT NO DOUBT AS TO WHAT THE
BATTLE WAS ABOUT ALL ALONG.
THE LEFT’S DESIRE TO USE THE
SUPREME COURT TO IMPOSE LIBERAL
SOCIAL VALUES ON SOCIETY.
>> ANOTHER ISSUE THAT GIVES ME
GREAT PAUSE, IS JUDGE
KAVANAUGH’S EXTREME VIEW ON
GUNS.
THE CHALLENGING REALITIES WOMEN
FACE.
ROW V. WADE, WHAT KIND OF
MEDICAL CARE CAN YOU RECEIVE.
>> Laura: THIS HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR DECADES.
THE AMERICAN LEFT BELIEVES THE
COURT SHOULD BE A SUPER
LEGISLATURE, A BODY THAT MAKES
LAW RATHER THAN INTERPRETS LAW.
SINCE TRUMP ANNOUNCED HIS
CANDIDACY THE LEFT HAS BEEN IN
PERPETUAL RAGE MODE.
AND OF COURSE THIS CONTINUED
INTO THE NIGHT.
AND IT’S GOING ON GO ON FOR SOME
TIME.
THIS IS HOW THE THEY ATTEMPTED
TO INFLUENCE SUSAN COLLINS
BEFORE SHE ANNOUNCED HER VOTE.
CHECK IT OUT.
[ALL YELLING AT THE SAME TIME]
>> DON’T PUT A LIAR ON THE
COURT!
DON’T PUT A LIAR ON THE COURT!
>> Laura: AH, NICE.
THIS IS HOW THEY WORK THEIR
CHARMS ON DEMOCRAT JOE MANCHIN
AFTER HE ANNOUNCED HE WAS
SUPPORTING KAVANAUGH.
>> SHAME, SHAME, SHAME, SHAME,
SHAME, SHAME!
>> Laura: AT LEAST IT’S A
ONE-WORD CHANT, EASY TO FOLLOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS SHAMEFUL?
DEMOCRATS WHO USE VICTIMHOOD AS
THEIR DEFINING PRINCIPLE.
THEY’D RATHER HAVE PEOPLE
DEPENDENT ON GOVERNMENT,
HELPLESS WITHOUT IT, ESPECIALLY
CERTAIN GROUPS, MINORITIES,
IMMIGRANTS, AND EVEN WOMEN.
WE’RE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THAT
WE CAN’T SURVIVE AND THRIVE
WITHOUT AN ACTIVIST COURT MAKING
UP NEW RIGHTS, FINDING THEM IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
ANYONE WHO CLAIMS VICTIM STATUS.
AND THEY DEMAND THAT WE BELIEVE
WE HAVE TO TAKE THEM AT THEIR
WORD REGARDLESS OF WHERE THE
FACTS LIE.
BUT FOR ALL OF THEIR SCREAMING
AND TIRESOME CHANTING, THE LEFT
BASICALLY COME UP EMPTY THIS
TIME.
MOST AMERICANS DON’T SEE
THEMSELVES AS VICTIMS.
WE’RE NOT POWERLESS OR WEAK.
WE’RE STRONG AND INDEPENDENT.
THIS WAS THE DEMOCRATS’
MISCALCULATION.
THEY THOUGHT EMOTIONAL EXTORTION
AND PROTESTER HISTRIONICS TO
BLOCK A WELL QUALIFIED SUPREME
COURT NOMINEE.
ONCE AGAIN, THEY LET THEIR RABID
POLITICAL IDEOLOGY BLIND THEM TO
POLITICAL IDEOLOGY BLIND THEM TOTHE FACT THAT THE AMERICANS ARE
THE FACT THAT THE AMERICANS ARE
FAIR MINDED, HAVE A BASIC
GOODNESS ABOUT THEM, AND THEY’RE
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE FUTURE.
THEY DON’T NEED AN ACTIVIST